The Joe Rogan experience.
I did have,
I did a good practical joke
at that place one time.
There's this comedian named James Sibley.
Great Guy. Very funny southern dude. Uh,
we were sharing a condo somewhere,
I think in myrtle beach. And uh,
as a joke,
I thought it'd be funny when he's leaving
to put a condom wrapper in his bag
and I go,
ha,
tell him how you so fast.
So I did that.
Right. And they did this happen to
you? Okay. No. Okay. So he goes away.
I don't see him for a year or two,
maybe three. And he's divorced now.
Well, the first thing he did, this is
Atlanta punchline he walked up to is like,
you motherfucker, you know what you did
to me. You want me got get divorced.
Like it was as long thing. I was like
two, I am so sorry. I was stupid.
It was just done. I already had,
I wouldn't even planned out.
It was sitting right there. I just do it
in there. Huh? Maybe he'll find it when,
as he's packing to go home. I didn't,
I didn't think yourself, you know,
so I felt really bad about it. He goes,
I'm going to get you back. And I'm like,
okay. And that stupid green room they
have in that corner at the punchline,
right where you're sitting in there,
there's no access to a bathroom
or if you just poke your head out,
everybody can see you like who's
in there? What's going on? Right.
So I'm sitting in there,
he goes, all right,
here's what I'm going to do when you go
on stage, because he was opening for me.
I'm going to put mustard all over
the door, knobs in here. Okay.
And you're going to be in such a hurry
to get out of there and go back to your
stupid merge title that
you're not even gonna.
Remember that I told you there's mustard
all over this door knob and you're just
going to grab mustard on your head.
It wasn't as good as me getting him with
a condom, obviously. But he was right.
Like I go on stage.
He told you he was going to do,
he told me he was going to do
it. I said, a cat's out the bag.
Jen's not going to happen. And of course
I grabbed it right away. I was like, okay.
Are you still close with them? Do
you know? Yeah. Well not, I mean,
as close as I can be, but
uh, we're good. We're fine.
Did you have to talk to his wife?
No. He's got a new life now.
I'm not going to be one. If it
was, it was the first step. Maybe.
So first spend the first name.
That's right. Yeah. You're
welcome. You're welcome.
New Eyes. Glass is half full.
Okay. Settle the fuck down.
Everybody welcome. New White.
Yeah. Yeah. It was like God's
plan. That's right. Yeah.
And where are we? I was like,
come on man. And a lot of ways,
what if God was one of us? He is. It's
me. It's not a song. He is. It is.
Who Sang that song? Jane Osborne, I
think. Yeah. You know what's really funny?
Am I right? Yeah. I was born
pretty close. Pretty close.
You're not impressed with the speed of
that. I was very quick. Thank you DJ.